مناظرات جمع التبرعات للحملات الانتخابية
المزيد من جمع التبرعات اتفاقيتين
ومناقشات أخرى
وأخيراً التصويت ، تجري الانتخابات الرئاسية الأمريكية
كل أربع سنوات في أول
ثلاثاء في تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر)
ولكن يوم الانتخابات هو في الحقيقة مجرد الخطوة الأخيرة
في عملية طويلة مدتها عام
يبدأ مع الانتخابات التمهيدية عندما
تصوت الولايات على  من يجب أن يكون المرشح
لكل حزب سياسي
هناك حزبان سياسيان رئيسيان
يقرهما معظم الأمريكيين
بالحزب الجمهوري والحزب الديمقراطي
يعتبر الحزب الجمهوري
على يمين الطيف السياسي
الداعم للمواقف التي تعتبر أكثر
تحفظًا بينما يسقط الديمقراطيون
على اليسار ، تعتبر المواقف الداعمة
أكثر
ليبرالية كل صيف قبل
الانتخابات ، يعقد الحزبان أحداثًا لمدة أسبوع
تسمى مؤتمرات
لاختيار مرشحهم رسميًا ،
سترسل كل ولاية مندوبين إلى
المؤتمرات
الذين يعملون كممثلين
للنتائج من الانتخابات التمهيدية في
أركنساس.  لبيرني
ساندرز و 2  7 أصوات لرئيسنا القادم ،
جو بايدن ، المرشح الذي يفوز
بأغلبية هؤلاء المندوبين ، ثم
يقبل الترشيح
حتى يتعين على الرئيس الحالي أن
يعيد ترشيحه من قبل حزبهم.
قضى بالفعل فترتين
لا يمكنهم الترشح لها مرة أخرى بمجرد أن
يتم
تأمين المرشحين للانتخابات العامة على الرغم من
أن المرشحين قد يهاجمون
بعضهم البعض لأنهم حملتهم لن
يواجهوا في الواقع حتى المناقشات
قبل شهر من الانتخابات
عندما تكون في النهاية  وقت التصويت هناك
ثلاث طرق للقيام بذلك
عن طريق البريد والاقتراع لأولئك الذين لا
يستطيعون الوصول إلى صناديق الاقتراع
عن طريق التصويت المبكر الذي يحدث قبل أيام أو
أسابيع من
يوم الانتخابات وبالذهاب إلى صناديق الاقتراع في يوم الانتخابات
تاريخيًا فقط حوالي 50 إلى  60 في
المائة من الأمريكيين المؤهلين
يصوتون بالفعل في الولايات المتحدة ،
ولا يفوز المرشح بأغلبية الأصوات تلقائيًا ، ويستخدم الولايات المتحدة
نظامًا يسمى elec  هيئة toral
التي تمنح كل ولاية قدرًا معينًا
من الأصوات الانتخابية ، يتم
تحديد مقدار الأصوات الانتخابية التي
تحصل عليها الولاية من خلال عدد
الممثلين الذين لديهم في الكونغرس
إذا حصل المرشح على أكبر عدد من الأصوات في
ولاية حصلوا على الأصوات الانتخابية
لتلك الولاية
باستثناء في  نبراسكا وماين ، حيث
يتم منحهما بناءً على نتائج الولاية والمقاطعة ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى 270 من أصل 538 صوتًا انتخابيًا
لتصبح رئيسًا ،
وقد صوتت بعض الولايات تاريخيًا
للجمهوريين تسمى الولايات الحمراء
والبعض الآخر صوتت تاريخيًا
بالديمقراطية وتسمى الولايات الزرقاء
بعض الولايات تتأرجح  الدول مما يعني أن
الناخبين قد تأرجحوا
بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
اعتمادًا على سنة الانتخابات
في عام عادي إذا كانت الانتخابات
ساحقة ، فيمكن استدعاء النتائج
بعد وقت قصير من إغلاق مراكز الاقتراع
في المساء
ولكن إذا كان المرشحون المقربون
لن يفوزوا أو  خطابات الامتياز
حتى الساعات الأولى من الصباح إذا
كان المرشحون المقربون للغاية
يمكنهم طلب ذلك  باستخدام إعادة فرز الأصوات في
ولايات معينة في عام 2000 ، فاز جورج بوش
بولاية فلوريدا بحوالي
1700 صوتًا فقط
بعد إعادة الفرز كان 327 صوتًا فقط
وفي النهاية كان على المحكمة العليا أن تنظر
في المصادقة على النتائج
بسبب covet 19 من المتوقع التصويت بالبريد
في الزيادة وتواجه الولايات
تحديات
مثل النقص في العاملين في الاقتراع ، فقد
يستغرق الأمر بعض الولايات أيامًا أو أسابيع
للانتهاء من نتائجها
بعد أن يؤدي كل ذلك الفائز اليمين
في يناير التالي
ويبدأ الناس على الفور تقريبًا في
الاستعداد للانتخابات التالية